uh this new album is well first of all
explain the title
so my new album is called thanks for
nothing
um and it's gonna be released in
February
and I really wanted to make a project
that was like geared towards the women
of course
um but Valentine's Day is coming up and
you know me I'm always speaking for my
ladies yep I'm always talking about
heartbreaks and relationship issues and
that's like my core so I was like it's
perfect time thanks for nothing it's the
album is that what you tell like X
that's what I tell my ex so you get you
go through a breakup it's like thanks
for nothing thanks for wasting my
time wasting my time that's it
you know thanks for nothing is that the
hardest part about going through a bad
breakup where it's like I just wasted
like some Prime real estate in my life
with this guy of course that's
the that's the worst part about it you
can't get time back but you can get
lessons from it true yeah that's the
upside you know you always learn yeah
learn from everything but
I like how you said that though it's
like man
took my time and wasted it
that's true because if you're in your
like 20s early 30s like you're like yo
like this is the prime of my life yeah
don't take that lightly don't waste my
time exactly
um and I'm 27 so like it is like that
Prime you know that age where you know
you don't have time
yeah
I sure know we don't have no more time
to waste so you and uh Mr Berg AKA hit
maker how many times Platinum 100
millions of I mean what are we at Berg
over there excuse me
120 and so non-shock this guy's crazy
super talented got a ear for hit records
how uh you guys have been working
together for a while now but in terms of
your guys's cohesion it's almost like
the r b version of like DJ Premiere and
Guru from gang star where like you guys
are like very much like in sync with
each other and putting these records
together explain like your guys's
relationship and the chemistry there
you know what's really dope about us
working together we both from Chicago
yes you are yep so when I when I met
hitmaker it was very comfortable
you know like I'm an artist where I like
to kind of go in the studio alone and
you know I like to just kind of be free
and have the room to myself right when
he came in it was easy to work with him
I didn't feel like bombarded it wasn't
like you know singing like this do this
a lot of producers are pushy right and
it's not like that Wham and he
understands me too like leave from the
shot so he get my my lingo you know he
understand my language
so it just made it really easy
um yeah I feel like you guys are going
to your guys like because he is he he
did the whole album
yeah the whole album executive produced
the whole album wow so so that's major
you know what I mean like like you say
120 million it's a lot a billion close
to a billionaire
13 billion streams yeah that's major
that's a lot you know yeah super slept
on guy over there sitting on the on the
rug over there we need more chairs by
the way sorry guys it's the first day in
a new place we need more chairs it's
obvious yeah congrats it's really nice
yeah the front building is where it's at
but nah we're here uh for you is there
any features on this album
so I have one feature very very very
special feature
um
should I give away the surprise guys
so Ty dollar sign is on this album
dollar sign
yes listen that's like legendary for me
I really really
you know just always have been a great
fan of Ty dollars that's how he's just
so good he's just like he's like a cheat
code for sure it's a cheat cheat code um
but on our record we're going back and
forth so it's a real real record did you
ever think that Ty and Berg look like
they could be kin to each other in some
capacity like if this bird grew out
dreadlocks like it's the eyes he might
be able to have a second career as a Ty
Dollar Sign stand-in you know what I
mean
you've heard that before Berg
or am I being am I being like 10 racist
right now
[Laughter]
yo for sure the iced tea thing okay yeah
iced tea no iced tea son no
he is iced Tea's son
that's Iceberg right there for sure
there it is